foreign
[Music]
depart but it's been delayed there's a
child crying on the plane and this man's
upset so he's been yelling about the
child crime
together
do you say please smack the baby
no
he said smack the baby no he said he
said please smack the paper
hi we're here with Delta is that your
child
thank you
hey that would be wild for somebody to
smack somebody else's baby just curious
what do you think is going to happen
when you smack the paper I know do you
think the babies came back oh come on
man like usually
oh I feel like I feel like I'll stop
Google like when these things don't
happen I feel like whenever is the
reverse when you're older no what the
[__] is about
but when you're a kid if I smack you
you're just gonna I've seen a woman
smack a police officer and the police
officer smacked her back yeah
what the [__] does that have to do he
said if that child was a black baby that
wouldn't be what you think they they
because
we give baby I'm gonna wear Airline into
flight attendants are y'all out here
smacking black babies
not werewolf [__] did you not see what
they did to that old Asian man when they
dragged him through the aisle all bloody
they beat the [__] out Hey listen
whatever policies they got I can assure
you they're not racially segregated
[Music]
and all this time you're making more
noise than the baby true you're making
more noise than a baby complaining about
the baby crying you crying you crying
like a baby
stupid that's
[Music]
so is the baby and the flight attendant
astutely States but you're a man yeah
but but
that's the that's the smartest thing
I've heard out of his whole thing the
babies you're crying too yeah but you're
a grown ass man bruh yeah you're a grown
ass man and guess what baby do they cry
they cry yo listen they Gon Cry they
gonna cry you may not always get to know
when but they will do it and you know
and it ain't always about parenting
babies cry ain't nobody who ever had a
baby who baby you never cry some of them
may be more below behaved some of them
not as
but they're babies I expect if I go on a
plane I expect the babies all the babies
to cry because you have to understand
now like
how loud it is they don't know where the
[__] there is and it's super loud
and now they're crying because you're
like yelling yeah because the energy
kids are hypersensitive to everything
happening around them they could feel
that atmosphere they can feel their
parents being stressed out because
you're yelling at them they can feel
their parents being embarrassed because
you're yelling about the child and so
the baby is absorbing that so you're
making things exponentially worse I've
seen babies Crown planes and then within
10 20 minutes they stop because the
batter is able to assuade them right
everyone around them is very supportive
or being kind but if you ratchet up the
stress the baby go yell more you out
here talking about did the baby pay
extra to yo just cause a baby shits in
his diaper doesn't mean you get to as
well as a grown man it's a [__] baby
stupid imagine the baby shot himself so
I
know you like The Bling yeah yeah
why
don't get me wrong
I understand the frustration one time
like on a short flight shut the [__] up
I took a long flight to Brazil one time
at full 10 hour direct flight and baby
was crying the whole time that [__] was
unpleasant I understand the frustration
but guess what this is part of living in
a society if we want young kids to be
able to grow up we're gonna have to be
around them at some point and
unfortunately sometimes you land on a
bad airplane where the kids crying the
whole time it is what it is and I also
understand the frustration of seeing a
kid crying and the parent just give up
and the parent just put in their
headphones and ignore the kid like no
[__] that's your child you gotta do
what you can to comfort it don't abstain
your [__] thing because you want a
plane now nah nah don't put that on
everybody else you could also do your
part to try to calm it down and most
parents do but you crying here like this
is embarrassing even your wife is beside
you and she's embarrassed and now you're
mad about this maybe making the plane
ride terrible guess what there ain't
gonna be no plane ride y'all gonna sit
in this [__] uh Park Bay waiting to
leave you're not going to leave because
they're not gonna let you go in the air
when you're that belligerent
you're stressing everybody else out and
now you're going to be on YouTube for
the whole world to see to be even more
embarrassed so you [__] played
yourself
you know what I would suggest you
because I take long uh playing right and
stuff like that and her babies in there
what I would suggest you to do is um
click on the link below and get uh my
earbuds they have isolation so you don't
really hear everything that's around you
it doesn't matter you're gonna have
you're not doing no free yet oh Well I
mean I liked them but I don't like them
but you know the thing is you better pay
me but but the thing you want free
advertisement not today
just awesome earbuds yeah there you go
I'm about to mute the whole [__]
now we're not doing no friend yeah yeah
yeah do that don't worry I get us paid
you know how I get this paid we ain't
doing it for free I know yeah that's how
that's I like the product so it's good
products
[Music]
that looks like a broken dish
yeah it's what happens when you're not
Your Own Boss
you end up in the economy yelling about
a baby on a plane
so now we're all getting deplaned
they're going to get the plane
that's what everybody gets out and he
gets out and everybody's gonna board a
plane and they're gonna stop his ass yo
listen yeah I hope that's what it is
make sure I share this video so this
guy's face is everywhere they looking
embarrassed now okay let's find out
pretty funny
he tried to plead his case that he had a
right to yell because there was two
adults with a crying baby and he
shouldn't have been Disturbed
well that's probably not how his wife
imagined their Florida getaway going
yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
my only the only sad thing is that
everybody else had to get off the plane
and this didn't happen quicker everyone
else's plan but the reason is they can't
they don't want to force them out right
they're going to get everybody off the
plane
nah nah nah they should have gave him
that Delta treatment I know but I was
passing and they know damn well they
can't do that with all the phones and
[__]
Hey listen if that Asian man would have
done half this [__] this [__] did they
would have definitely been like hey
again
yay yay get him out of here I can
understand that but he was already all
over the blaze uh and they don't want to
hurt nobody you know I mean like the
aisle super so him trying to struggle
with a [__] it would have been
stupid right yo listen so they probably
learned from their mistakes but yeah you
deploying everybody and then after that
you Chuck them out they should have done
long being Beach griffy's dad the same
way they did the Asian guy
wait he should have done them the same
way that's stupid he got to go but he
has to go but but that's the way that
they should act and that's the way that
he acted you get the [__] out and the
worst thing is that if you act like that
in the plane now you are on the list you
risk being on a no-fly list good you
understand what I'm saying which good
you were belligerent everybody yeah you
risk being on the no flight list flag is
not a it's not a right it's a privilege
it's a privilege so now get that privacy
like that if it's a kid we understand
it's a kid because you know my Florida
plans because you couldn't shut the [__]
up
I get it I already said what I know
about me he's not dancing and if you
make it that deep then maybe you should
buy yourself a private jet or maybe you
should start playing flying some some
some first class or something get
yourself some headphones like he said
there's no reason for you to be young
like that for flight attendants it's
stressful for them too you'll be making
their job harder for no reason you know
get them out of here and the worst thing
is that most flight attendants dream the
boarding they're not paid so you yelling
like that when the door is not closed
they're not getting paid to deal with
your ass your stupid ass so you're
making everybody miserable the kid was
being miserable but not everybody's
miserable everybody has to be playing
the the flight attendant that we're
there on time didn't get paid yep as a
matter of fact let me tell you something
about five tenants and most companies
they only get paid 15 minutes of the
boarding and after that it's free labor
so you yelling like like a like a stupid
ass [__] you there you're
ruining all their paycheck you're
ruining everybody's time and you don't
even get to fly how stupid are you
and I'm pretty sure that the way you act
you still think you was right man get
yeah get yourself a no get yourself a
no-flights list I don't care I don't
care you shouldn't be on the plane
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments you want to hear from me
[__] out of here